- [Instructor] We're told a
scale on a blue print drawing
of a house shows 10 centimeters
represents 2 meters.
What number of actual
meters are represented
by 18 centimeters on the blue print?
So pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
So the main thing to realize
is that a blue print drawing
is a scale drawing of
something in the real world.
In this case of a house.
And so what we can do
is set-up a little bit
of a table here, so let's put the drawing
on the left, so this is
the blue print drawing.
And then this is the real world.
Real world on the right.
And the unit that we're using,
the units that we're using
in our drawing are centimeters.
So we have centimeters over here.
And then the real world, we're
thinking in terms of meters.
And so let me make a
little bit of a table.
And so we see that 10
centimeters on the drawing
corresponds to 2 meters in the real world.
So 10 centimeters in the
drawing, corresponds to 2 meters
in the real world.
Then they ask us what
number of actual meters
are represented by 18
centimeters on the blue print?
So 18 centimeters on the
blue print would correspond
to what in the real world?
Well there's several ways to approach it.
One way to think about it is,
look to go from 10 to 18, we
are going to multiply by 1.8.
So to go from what 10
centimeters represents
in the real world to what
18 centimeters represents
in the real world, you would
similarly multiply by 1.8.
So times 1.8, which would give us 3.6.
3.6 what?
3.6 meters in the real world.
So 3.6 meters in the real world would be
what 18 centimeters on
the blue print represents.
Let's do another example.
Jaylynn draws a hen
with a scale of 2 units
on her graph paper represents 6 meters,
6 centimeters in the real world.
The hen is 16 units tall in the drawing.
What is the height in
centimeters of the actual hen?
So once again, pause this video
and see if you can figure that out.
Alright, so let's just
set-up our tables again.
So for our table, so we have our drawing,
and then we have the real, real world.
And in our drawing, it's
just these little units
on our graph paper, so I'll
call it just that, units.
And the real world,
we're thinking in terms
of centimeters, centimeters.
And so let me set-up a
little bit of a table here,
and so we know, and we
see that right over here
from this scale.
We can see two units
represent 6 centimeters
in the real world.
So two units in our drawing
represent six centimeters
in the real world, and
then they say the hen
is 16 units tall in the drawing.
So it's 16 units tall in the drawing.
What would that represent
in the real world
which would be the
actual height of the hen?
If two units represent six centimeters,
and now we have eight times as many units,
well that's gonna represent
eight times as many centimeters.
So six times eight is 48 centimeters.
So what is the height in
centimeters of the actual hen?
48 centimeters, 48 and we're done.